MALE SPEAKER: Good
morning, and welcome
to the first Talks
at Google of the year
here in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Today, it's my great pleasure
to introduce Amir Aczel.
Dr. Aczel is here to
discuss his new book,
"Finding Zero-- A
Mathematician's Odyssey
to Uncover the
Origins of Numbers."
This is the amazing story of his
lifelong obsession with finding
the origin of the
numbers we use every day
and have been using for
centuries and the journey that
took him around the world
to answer his questions.
Did I mention the
story is amazing?
You are absolutely going to
love this book, absolutely.
Dr. Aczel has
degrees from Berkeley
and the University of Oregon.
He's the author of over 20
general books and textbooks
including "Fermat's
Last Theorem."
He's been a Guggenheim
Fellow and a visiting scholar
in the History of
Science at Harvard.
Since 2003, he's been
a research fellow
with the BU Center
for Philosophy
and the History of Science.
And as of 2011, he's been
teaching math courses
at UMass Boston.
Please join me in
welcoming Amir Aczel.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIR ACZEL: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's really a great
pleasure and a great honor
for me to be here at
Google in Cambridge.
As you mentioned,
I've written 20 books,
and they're all about other
people, interesting people.
"Fermat's Last Theorem"
got me to write
about Andrew Wiles and other
amazing mathematicians.
I wrote a book about Descartes,
and a couple of books
about Einstein.
And this book is about me.
So it's a very, very
different story.
And the reason I had to
sort of-- it's not about me,
but I had to write in
the first person, which
is very unusual for me.
And it took a lot of
time to get used to.
It's almost like you're
writing about yourself.
And the reason was that I had
this obsession about trying
to trace the numerals, the Hindu
Arabic numerals, and especially
the zero.
And I wrote a book proposal.
When you're a writer, you
have to write a proposal.
The book doesn't write itself.
And you need a publisher
to be interested in it.
And this is the first book
in 20 that no publisher
was interested in.
I went to all the
publishers in New York,
and they all turned it down.
And the reason is that
the main character--
one of the reasons, the
main character in this book
is not like Einstein or
Andrew Wiles or Descartes.
It's a very boring guy.
He's this French academic
by the name of Coedes.
And he was so boring that
every publisher would just
read the proposal, and
they throw it away.
It's boring.
So I was very depressed.
I didn't know what to do.
I mean, this is the
topic I care a lot about,
and I can't write a book.
So I just got worse and worse.
And I got physically
ill at some point.
And I was about to
give up on everything.
And then, I got this grant
from the Sloan Foundation,
and I thought, wow.
They trust me to
write this book.
So I have to do it.
And the grant was to try to
rediscover the earliest zero.
Now, the zero is
discovered by the Maya,
and the Maya calendar
has a glyph for zero
which is like a crescent moon.
But that didn't go anywhere.
That remained in Mesoamerica.
But there is a zero
that became our zero.
And it was studied by
this guy that I mentioned,
Georges Coedes,
this French scholar.
And it disappeared.
And I wanted to find
it again to bring it
to the attention of
the world of science.
And it was also an
excuse to travel.
So if I can have the first
slide, that would be great.
So everybody knows the
numbers come from India.
Every Indian you
talk to will say, oh,
we invented the numbers.
And we invented the zero.
And so I sort of
took it by faith.
This odyssey of looking
for the first zero
was really an adventure to
try to find the first zero.
And it got me talking
to a lot of people,
emailing, phone
calling, writing letters
to some people who
are less accessible.
And at the conference
in Australia,
I met an Indian
researcher by the name
of C. K. Raju who gave a talk
at this international conference
at the University
of New South Wales.
And he said, people, you
don't really know this.
But the Indians
invented everything.
Einstein's relativity
came from India.
And Euclid's theorems
come from India.
The Pythagorean theorem
was invented in India.
And he went on and on.
The audience got very upset.
They would have pelted
him with rotten eggs,
but they're slightly
more polite,
and there were no eggs around.
At any rate, everybody
got very irritated.
But when I got the
grant, I thought, well,
he seems to know about India and
the things that happened there.
And so I went to
India to meet him.
So India has a lot of temples.
And there are markets where
you can buy manuscripts.
And I was sort of
looking for things,
like a fishing expedition.
Let's see what I can find.
And I came into contact with
a Japanese mathematician
who had traveled, by the name
of Hiyashi, Takao Hayashi, who
had traveled to this part of
India called Khajuraho which
has these really amazing
statues on temples.
And they get more and
more graphic, let's say.
But I took out all
the slides that
were more explicit
because there's really
no end to how
graphic they become.
And people go there
from all over the world
to see these statues.
There's some hints of them.
I don't know, maybe not.
Maybe I was censoring
this too much.
And then, there are all
these erotic statues.
And then, there are numbers.
And this is a magic square
that was known since the 1800s.
But after a while,
Hayashi found it.
But he forgot where it was.
So he told me it was
somewhere in Khajuraho.
So I spent a day looking for
it, and I rediscovered it.
If you Google Khajuraho, you
will find that magic square.
But there's no photograph
of it because nobody
knew where it was.
And it's rewritten
in our numerals.
But since you're all
brilliant people,
I'm sure you can figure
out these numerals.
So they're different from ours.
And don't be fooled if something
looks like our numeral.
It's not.
They are very different.
Some of them are similar
and almost the same.
But they're really
mostly very different.
My wife, who is not
a mathematician,
figured it out in
about 10 minutes.
So I'm sure some of you
maybe already figured it out.
So you know about
a magic square.
A four by four magic square,
a normal magic square,
a regular one, it has
the numbers from 1 to 16.
Has to have a sum of 34.
It's an easy proof, too.
You can probably prove
it to yourselves.
So knowing that the sum
of everything is 34,
you can do it mathematically
by setting up equations.
But you can also do it the way
my wife did, just by guessing,
I guess.
And it's a cool exercise
to try and do it.
I went there because I was
fascinated by the magic square.
But I also wanted to
see early numerals.
I said 11th century.
We don't really know.
On Wikipedia, it
says 10th century.
It's either 10th
or 11th century.
It's very early.
Four by four, three
by threes have
been known in
Persian and in China
and different
parts of the world.
A four by four is
more complicated.
And if you set the sums, what's
cool about this magic square
is it's not only the two
full diagonals, all the rows,
and all the columns, but also
every four by four in a corner,
like the-- oh, two
by two in a corner.
The one on top, to the
right and to the left,
and the central one.
So this is a very
sophisticated magic square
that has many possibilities
of adding to the sum of 34.
Which, I think, is magical.
Maybe that's why they put it
next to all these very strange,
sensuous statues and
phrases all over.
And nobody knew where it was.
I had to ask maybe 30 people.
And then, there was
a French tourist
who heard me ask his guide.
And he said yes, I've seen it.
And it's in a different part
of Khajuraho, less visited.
So the main part is the
western group of temples.
And this is in the eastern
group, which is across town.
There's nobody there except
dogs and a few children
begging for money.
For some reason,
nobody goes there.
And this is at the
Parshvanath Temple,
which is what that piece
of information was lost.
And here's a better view of it.
So I forgot to tell
you the best part.
So I did go there.
And I did trace also the
earliest zero in India
to a place called
Gwalior, and that zero
comes from the mid 9th
century, 850 something.
And there was a big controversy
in the '30s and '20s
about who invented the zero.
There was a British scholar
by the name of G. R. Kaye,
K-A-Y-E, who was actually
an expert on India,
but was very racist.
And he claimed that the
Indians didn't invent anything,
sort of the opposite
of C. K. Raju today.
And he was the first person to
study the Bakhshali manuscript,
which is very important in
the history of mathematics,
but undated.
If they could date it-- it's
made of bark, tree bark.
If they could just
take a tiny bit of it
and radiocarbon date it, the
whole history of mathematics
would come into much,
much clearer view.
And we would know what the
sequence, the chronology,
was like.
But the Brits don't
allow you to do that.
It's in Oxford, at the library
there, at the Bodleian Library.
And so we don't know.
It could be first few
centuries, even BC or AD,
around that time.
Or it could be 1200.
So he claimed that it was 1200s,
1300s, something like that,
Kaye himself.
And he dissed the Indian
chronology by saying,
well, the Indians claim
that their history goes
back several million years.
So of course they don't know
what they're talking about.
And he claimed, his theory
was that the zero was
invented either in
the West, in Europe,
and brought through
Arab trade to the east,
or the Arabs
themselves invented it.
It's unlikely that
the Indians had
anything to do with the zero.
So there is this guy by the
name of Georges Coedes who is
originally a Hungarian Jew
who immigrated to France
and changed his name so
it looks very French with
the C-O-E-D-E-S and
an accent grave,
and the O and the E are
ligated, and so it looks very,
very French.
And he just had this
natural ability--
I'm very fascinated by people
who have a natural ability
to do things.
Ramanujan comes to mind, as
a mathematician, just out
of the blue can come up
with these identities.
And nobody understands
where they come from.
And he can just invent
or discover them.
And he said a goddess, I guess,
from one of these statues,
the Hindu goddess Parvati
gave him all this information.
And you all know the
story about Hardy,
great mathematician,
British mathematician,
brought him to England
and tried to figure out
how he got this knowledge.
And Coedes had a similar
ability of understanding
dead languages, like old Khmer.
He could read a stele, and
within a short period of time,
translate it.
Just an incredible gift.
And he ended up translating
into French 2,000 steles
in Cambodia and Thailand.
And one of these steles that
he found had an early zero.
The problem with the Indian zero
in Gwalior is that it's 800s.
And that's coincidental with
the caliphate in Baghdad,
the big, very
extensive Arab trade.
So if you have a zero
in India from that time,
it could've come
there from Europe
or from the Arabs,
or the other way.
There's no conclusive proof.
But if you could--
what Coedes knew
was that if he could find a zero
that's earlier than Gwalior,
the earliest Indian
zero, he could
prove that the zero was an
eastern invention because it
predates that Arab trade.
And that's exactly
what he found.
He found a zero in Cambodia.
And basically was
able to completely
destroy the theory of
Kaye, and to establish
that the zero is Eastern.
But everything that he
was basing this theory on
disappeared.
The reason it disappeared was
because of the Khmer Rouge.
So I knew that, and that's what
I got the grant from the Sloan
Foundation, to try and
find, to rediscover
the stele that may or
may not still exist.
We didn't know.
But I guess they had faith that
maybe I'll be able to find it.
And once I got the grant,
it's like, I had to do it.
I had to find it.
So my first stop after going
to India was to go to Bangkok.
And I kind of used this
as just a great, fun city
to go to and an excuse to show
pictures of places I like.
This is one port and temple
there, and all these Buddhas.
And it doesn't want to go.
And of course, all the
pickpockets are not Thai.
They're foreign, foreign.
And so this is why I went there.
I couldn't write-- the software
wasn't written by Google,
so it doesn't work very well.
It doesn't allow you to
write the name correctly.
The font is-- I wasn't
able to add all the French.
OK, so you say, why did
you go to all these places?
So I need to explain this.
Once I started
researching it, I sort of
became obsessed with the
philosophical idea of,
why the zero?
Why would the zero be
invented in the east and not
in the west?
And it was, I think,
we know conclusively
that it's an eastern invention.
I call it an invention.
Of course, mathematicians
would argue
is it an invention or discovery?
Most mathematicians I've polled,
including some people we've
talked about earlier,
most mathematicians
think, of course,
that numbers exist.
They're the Platonic
point of view.
The numbers exist
regardless of us.
But the ability
to write something
is sort of an invention.
You invent the zero.
And the zero that I'm
interested in here
is not the zero, just
an idea of emptiness,
even though it's
very interesting.
But the zero as a placeholder
which allowed our number system
to work so well.
If you try to construct
a multiplication using
Roman numerals,
then you can see why
our numerals are so much better.
So what happens algebraically,
when you add the zero,
you turn it into a ring.
And you can do things.
And these are stacked
rings for each decimal,
for each position.
And you couldn't do that
without something like a zero
because you need to
hold an empty space
for the further ones.
So you can write 2 is just 2.
But 2 followed by 0 is 20 or
200 with two 0's, and so on.
So it's also an
intellectual idea
for creating a number
system-- and it's independent
of the base, of course.
It doesn't matter
whether the base
is 8 or 10 or 2, the way
a computer would work.
So the idea of
doing that is really
what gives our numbers
their efficiency and power.
But the idea of
writing something
that means nothing,
there's so many, of course,
people play with language.
Nothing means nothing, or
nothing means everything,
and so on.
So nothing, the idea of nothing,
is a sophisticated idea.
And I became convinced,
maybe for no reason,
that it's an eastern
idea for a reason.
And that it may have come from
Buddhism, the void in Buddhism,
you know?
When you meditate, if
you're a Buddhist, I guess.
You imagine the void.
And so I went to
Luang Prabang in Laos,
because that's the one
town in the world that
has more Buddhist
monks per square foot
than anywhere in the world.
And it's also a very
interesting place.
Has anybody been there?
I would go there
soon because it's
a gem that's going
to be destroyed.
They're building a
high speed rail line
from China and a new airport.
And it's a very
authentic town that's
both French colonial and
Asian at the same time.
You can see their art is
very intricate and different
from what you see in Thailand.
So I was talking
to all these monks.
And I became convinced
that yes, the zero
does come because they even
tell you, when we meditate,
we think of the void.
And then, we start counting.
So from emptiness,
there's a one, two,
and we count when we breathe
in and we breathe out.
And so I think it's
logical that the void does
come from some eastern idea.
Maybe not Buddhism, but the
eastern mind of the early
centuries was able to
conceive of nothingness.
And the Mekong goes
through this place.
And 200 kilometers
southeast in that direction
is where the earliest
zero was found,
in a place that
looks just like this,
but it is just further south.
There was a temple
there dated to 683.
So it's 200 years
before Gwalior.
And that's where
Coedes found his zero.
There's the Mekong again.
So I finally got serious
about this search.
And I knew I had
to go to Cambodia
to try to find this lost
stele with the first zero.
It's not necessarily
the first zero.
In the 80 years that passed
since Coedes analyzed it,
nothing else was
found that's earlier.
So it's the earliest
because of that,
because we don't have
anything earlier than that.
But likely, the zero was
invented before that.
Coedes defined these
civilizations as Indianized
because they were Hindu
and later Buddhist and back
to Hindu.
There's a back and
forth with religions.
So if you've been to Angkor Wat,
it was built as a Hindu temple
to Vishnu, and then became
Buddhist, and Hindu,
and Buddhist, and depending
on the kings which ruled.
But this is Phnom
Penh, and I went
there to meet the Deputy
Minister of Culture and Fine
Arts of Cambodia because after
about two years of emailing,
writing, phone calling,
I got to this person who,
for some reason,
agreed to talk to me.
And I needed doors opened to me.
Otherwise, I couldn't
find anything.
And I don't know why, this is
a guy-- Hab Touch is his name.
They called him His
Excellency, Hab Touch.
And he goes around the world.
He comes to New
York often to try
to get back to Cambodia all
the lost art that was sold out
of the country during the
years of the Khmer Rouge rule.
Maybe you've read about it
in the "New York Times."
There are stories
about it all the time.
And he goes to all the
museums in the world
and tries to negotiate
the return of the art.
For some reason, he thought
that maybe this was interesting.
And I met him.
And then, he sent
me to this place,
which is near Angkor Wat.
This is called Bayon, which
is outside Angkor Wat, built
by Jayavarman VII.
And the zero is there.
But I didn't know that.
He just sent me there
and told me to look.
These are the faces
of Jayavarman VII,
the great Buddhist King
who built Angkor Wat.
So there's a place
near Angkor Wat
in a clearing in
the jungle that's
called Angkor Conservation.
And after all these years
and months of searching,
I came there.
And a phone call from this
man opened the doors to me
because this is
closed to the public.
Nobody can go there.
And what it is is a repository
for all the art that
was destroyed by
the Khmer Rouge.
They tried to restore it,
but mostly they do nothing.
It's just a storehouse.
This is in a shed that's about
twice the size of this room.
And that's what you see there.
And the great statues,
they were just destroyed.
At some point-- I don't
have a slide of that,
but an archaeologist
there showed me
a statue where you can see
clear marks of destruction.
So the Khmer Rouge were a
little bit like the Taliban.
I don't know if you
remember before 9/11,
maybe a few years before, they
blew up those two large Buddha
statues in Afghanistan
for no reason.
And the Khmer Rouge
did the same thing.
They weren't Muslim.
I guess they were
Communists, the Khmer Rouge.
They tortured and
killed 1.7 million
of their own people, Cambodians.
And then, they
destroyed all the art.
So I'm not sure why they
would want to do that.
But so the place is full
of this just discarded art.
And I had to look through it.
They told me, if it exists,
then maybe it's here.
But they may have destroyed it.
So there it is.
I found it.
So it took a while, maybe
half a day going through.
And I finally found it.
This is K-127, the
number Coedes gave it.
This is from behind.
And this is from the front.
And here are two pictures
of the front of this stele.
And the zero is dead center
on the right photograph,
right there.
And this is what it says.
It says, the Caka 605 year
began on the fifth day
of the waning moon.
And 605, this is better.
So you can see the
zero is the dot.
So why the dot?
A zero discovered sometime
later in Indonesia
is a year younger than this one.
So this is the
oldest zero we know.
And apparently, the
Khmer Rouge didn't
think this was important.
And that's why it
survived destruction.
There is damage to
it, but maybe it
was the Khmer Rouge-- I have no
idea-- but not the part that's
important.
You can see the damage on the
last slide, on the top there.
We don't know whether this
damage was done by the Khmer.
It doesn't look like
a statue, so they
wouldn't have wanted to
destroy it necessarily.
But it does have damage in
the top and on the side here.
And you can see the zero on the
second line from the bottom.
So why is it a dot?
The other zero from
Indonesia, which
is-- so I need to explain
the dating, though.
So Caka began in 78 AD.
And this is the year
605 of the Caka era.
And so 605 plus 78 is 683, which
is a prime number, by the way.
So 683 is the date.
And therefore, it's two
centuries earlier than Gwalior.
And there was no extensive
Arab trade at the time,
and this is further east.
So that is very strong
proof of the hypothesis
that the zero is indeed
an eastern invention.
The Arabs today
use a dot for zero,
a circle, an uneven
circle that's
kind of fatter on
the bottom is a five.
And the dot is a zero.
And we use a circle as a zero.
So it is a good question.
Why was it a dot or a zero?
But apparently the
two forms still
co-exist and evolved
at the same time.
The zero, circular
one in Indonesia,
and this dot in Cambodia.
And these cultures were
Indianized in the sense
that they were
Hindu at the time.
And this comes from
a Hindu temple.
And they used Sanskrit
in addition to old Khmer.
So the story would end
now, but it didn't.
Because I was stupid.
I'm standing there,
looking at it.
And I was euphoric.
I thought, I finally
found-- took me really
five years to find it.
I didn't know what to do.
Suddenly, these two women
walked into this shed.
Nobody ever comes
into this shed.
And they're wearing lab
coats and speaking Italian.
And as I described
in the book, I
was raised on a cruise
ship in the Mediterranean.
I speak French and
Italian fairly well.
And I'd been
traveling for months
and didn't talk to anybody
other than these phone calls
and trying to beg
people for information.
And usually somebody
says, oh, I know
somebody who might
know somebody,
and that kind of thing.
It was just this
kind of research,
like trying to find somebody who
knows somebody who might know
something or might
talk to you about it.
And I got a lot of nos.
The director of the
museum right there
just refused to talk to me.
And the head of this
place, Angkor Conservation,
just hung up the phone on me
and, in an email, told me,
I can't talk to you.
And that's why I had
to go to the government
to go over their heads.
And then, of course,
they were there.
But so these two women walk in.
They speak Italian.
So I started to speak
Italian with them.
And I said, you know, this is
the oldest zero in history?
And they said, really?
Thank you so much
for telling us.
We'll take it.
And they took it.
So it weighs a couple of tons.
They didn't take it right away.
But they said, we
run a lab here.
And we teach the
Cambodian students
how to restore
archaeological artifacts.
And since you told
us it's important,
we'll use that,
all these stones.
And it looks fine to me.
I hate to have
somebody restore it.
This is crazy.
And I tried to say,
there's nothing.
No, no, we'll take it.
And they took it.
So this archaeologist from
Palermo who runs this place
has control of all the artifacts
because the Cambodians can't
handle it themselves.
So they got somebody from
the University of Palermo
to come and teach them
how to do archaeology.
And she's in control.
And so I told her
it was important.
She took it, and she went
to write articles about it.
And she took it into her lab.
And I thought,
OK, it's lost now.
I went back to Bangkok,
and an art dealer
who helped me on my way
said, it's lost now.
The mafia is going to
get its hands on it.
She's from Palermo.
And it will be sold
somewhere in the world
for millions of dollars.
It's the first zero.
You told me it's important.
It's gone.
There's nothing you can do.
I came back to Boston
after everything.
I found it, and now it's gone.
I thought it should
be in a museum.
And then I thought, the
grant had run out long ago.
And so I paid my own
way back to Cambodia.
I went back to Phnom Penh.
I stayed in the same
hotel from which
that picture was taken
that I showed you.
And I asked for a meeting with
Hab Touch, his excellency,
the Deputy Minister of
Culture and Fine Arts.
And he came to the
hotel to meet me.
And I thought,
I'll wait for him.
He said, no, wait in your room.
I'll come, and I'll call you.
And he came, and we had
dinner in the hotel.
And I took my PC,
and I showed it.
And I said, here, this
is the oldest zero.
And you helped me find it.
If it hadn't have been
for your phone calls,
I wouldn't have
been allowed there.
And he said, that's wonderful.
It belongs in a museum.
And I said, that's
where I want it to go.
And he says, I want you to
write the description of it.
And I wrote one right away.
And I emailed it to him.
And he said, don't worry.
It's going to go to the museum.
This was in 2013.
I rediscovered this
stone on January 2, 2013.
And nothing happened.
I emailed him again.
Not a word.
I thought, maybe my friend
in the gallery in Bangkok
was right.
It's probably sold
at auction somewhere.
It's gone.
They won't talk
about it anymore.
And then, my sister died.
So it seemed like it would
have nothing to do with this,
but it did.
My sister was interested in
Cambodia and the Khmer Rouge
era in particular.
It's because of
her interest in it
that I got interested
in Southeast Asia.
And that's what got me to do
this research even before I
started to do the research.
And when she died, she
left some amount of money.
And I thought, I
can commemorate her
by paying for this piece
to be moved to the museum.
So I emailed them, and they
hadn't been answering me
for months, maybe over a year.
And the minute I
mentioned money,
not only His
Excellency responded,
but the Minister of
Culture and Fine Arts
herself wrote me
an email saying,
thank you so much for wanting
to support this important
find that you made
of the first zero.
And we'll place it in a
museum and everything.
So I'm in the process
of going to Cambodia
and trying to arrange-- I
haven't seen it yet, though.
So I'm not sure that
it hasn't been stolen.
You always have this fear
in the back of your mind.
Maybe they're saying yes, yes,
because they want the money.
But they haven't talked
about this for a long time.
And maybe the Sicilian
archaeologists
did spirit it out
of the country.
I wondered how a piece of stone
like that weighing a few tons
can be taken out of Cambodia.
But the art dealers
told me, no problem.
They just put it on a crate, the
crate, they put it on a ship,
and it's gone.
Who knows?
But they promised me that
they have it under control,
and as soon as
they get the money,
they'll place it in a museum.
So I think it's
important because there's
one thing you read in
a book or in an article
about some kind of a discovery,
or an artifact, and it's gone.
That's not the same.
When you are able to see it
and touch it, it's in a museum,
and study it further, then
that is, I think, of value.
And I even found a place
in a museum, the National
Cambodian Museum in Phnom
Penh, where it should go.
There's a little room
in the corner of it.
It's sort of a square
display like that that's
dedicated to the
seventh century.
And that's where it should go.
And there's some art
from Sambor in Mekong,
where this comes from.
So that's the end of the
story at this minute.
Thank you very much.
If you have any
questions, I'll be--
[APPLAUSE]
AMIR ACZEL: I'll be glad
to try and answer them.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So as you
mentioned, the importance
of zeroes for place
value, and I guess
just a little more context,
someone reading this stele,
were they already familiar
with the idea of place value,
but had just never
seen a numeral yet
that had a zero in
the middle of it?
Or is place value
itself a novel thing
as of the writing of this
that the reader would
have had to have some education
or training to expect?
Does that make sense?
AMIR ACZEL: Yes.
I worked as a statistician
for many years.
And one of the problems
we do with estimation
is suppose you want to estimate
the left point of support
of a distribution.
So the minimum point.
And so you use the
smallest order statistic.
If you look at data, that's
the last one towards the left.
But there's always bias.
If you know about bias,
this is a biased estimator.
It's always biased because you
can't-- this is the smallest
value you could have.
You can't always-- if it's
a continuous distribution,
probability of 0 of
hitting it exactly.
So we don't know
how early this is.
So we have to see it in context.
So my guess is because of that
bias inherent in an estimation,
this is a kind of an
estimation process.
You dig up new steles and
new archaeological things.
And each one of them
is a data point.
So the Gwalior one
in India is one.
And then, you go
200 years earlier.
In the last 80 years, nobody has
found anything older than this.
So we don't know.
But seeing it in
context, you may
imagine maybe this or an
earlier piece of stone
like that, maybe 200
years earlier than that,
where somebody has this idea.
I need to write the year 605.
So the Babylonians
just left a blank.
They had a very sophisticated
number system based on 60.
So you'd have the 0 power
would be the units, the same as
for us.
And the power one for us
would be the tens for them.
It's 60s, right?
So two 60s or three 60s,
like we have 30 or 20?
And then the next
power would be 3,600.
That was a huge base,
and therefore it
was not as efficient.
But they didn't have a zero.
But they'd leave a blank.
So one can imagine
that maybe when
they wanted to write 505, 100
years earlier, the year 505
of the Caka era, they'd write 5
and leave a blank, or just 55,
and sometimes when somebody
sees it, he or she will say,
well, it has to be 505
because we know it's not 55.
And that's what the
Babylonians did.
The example with
the Babylonians,
they used things in context.
Like you say, in
a modern example,
say something costs $6.95.
We're talking about a magazine.
It would be $6.95.
If I said $695 for an airline
ticket, you know it's $695.
So that's-- the way I understand
it-- what the Babylonians did.
There was a blank sometimes.
There was a blank, and you could
understand from the context.
At some point, some
person, then or earlier,
decided to chisel a dot there
to say the 6 is for hundreds
and the 5 is for units, and
there's nothing for the 10s.
So that's my guess.
I hope I answered your question.
AUDIENCE: I just visited
Chichen Itza a couple weeks ago,
and I'm totally impressed
by the Mayan culture.
But did you have a
date on the Mayan zero?
AMIR ACZEL: I think it's 37.
AUDIENCE: 37?
AMIR ACZEL: Yeah, AD
37, just from memory.
But I know very little about it.
Something like that.
The number 37 pops into mind.
So I think it's 37.
AUDIENCE: So thank you for your
previous answer about the place
value represented by the blank.
How far back does that go?
AMIR ACZEL: How far
back does that go?
Well, the Babylonian
culture is very old.
So 2000 BC, something like that.
So Plimpton 322, the
famous clay tablet at Yale,
is 1650 something
like that BC, BCE
depending on how
you want to call it.
So it's something
like 3,600 years.
AUDIENCE: The concept of
zero goes back to then, then.
It's just the symbol of zero?
AMIR ACZEL: Right.
I think so.
That's a good point.
Maybe the Babylonians didn't
need the Buddhist void.
The Buddha was born much later.
There goes my theory.
Good point.
AUDIENCE: The other
question is you
were talking about
things like 695.
Do we know where the
final zero was first used?
So this is not a medial zero.
It's possible that it
was not contemporaneous.
I don't know.
AMIR ACZEL: A year
later, there's
a zero from Panin
Bank in Indonesia,
a stele that you can
still see in a museum
there in Panin Bank.
And it is a circle.
So they co-existed apparently.
The oldest one is a dot, but--
AUDIENCE: What I meant
was it's possible
that you might write
605 as 6, 0, 5,
but you write 600 as just 6.
So when is the first
evidence that you
have a zero at the
end of a number?
AMIR ACZEL: That's a good point.
AUDIENCE: Is that
a different issue?
I don't know.
Maybe it happened at the
same time, maybe it didn't.
I don't know.
AMIR ACZEL: Right.
I see what you're saying, right.
I don't know.
I have no answer to that.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: If I
understand correctly,
you dated this to 683
because of the text 605.
But do you have evidence that
that text wasn't written years
later?
AMIR ACZEL: Right, so
that's a very good question.
The temple there was
built around that time.
Around 683, and we know
that from stylistic forms
on the door frames, lintels,
and all these things there.
So that site was
studied extensively
by Coedes and by others.
So we know when it was built.
So for example, yeah,
that's how you know.
So we know when the
temple was built.
So maybe it's-- well, 683,
they wouldn't write it before
because they were actually
describing an event that
happened at that time.
They were saying, the era
began on the fifth day
of the waning moon.
It seems like something
that's localized in time.
Unless, hm, could you write
it at a different time,
year 605 of the Caka era began
on the fifth day of the waning
moon?
Maybe they're talking like we
would be reading the Bible.
Something happened on a
certain-- yeah, it could be.
But the temple was
built around that time.
It's a seventh century temple.
The styles are seventh century.
And Hab Touch
himself is actually
an expert on Cambodian art.
And he actually has classified
the Cambodian art styles
into five different styles.
And the style of Sambor-- there
are two Sambors, by the way.
And for several
months, I was going
to the wrong Sambor trying
to look for it years before.
There's a Sambor that's near
Siem Reap, where Angkor Wat is.
And this Sambor is all
the way on the other side.
This is northeast of Phnom Penh.
And the other one is northwest.
But they're both called Sambor.
One is Sambor something
else, and this
is Sambor on the Mekong.
The other one is Sambor Prei
Kuk, and this is Sambor Mekong.
And they're both
seventh century.
So the style is very well known.
The artistic style
of everything,
so we know it's seventh century.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMIR ACZEL: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I had originally had
the same question about this,
and that other inscription
in India, right?
How do you know somebody
didn't scribble it
into the temple
walls later, right?
But the other question I had
was is there any use of it
in arithmetic at some
point in old Khmer?
AMIR ACZEL: We don't know.
In terms of the old Khmer,
this is all we have.
So we have no knowledge
about their arithmetic.
It would be very
interesting to find out.
This is all we have.
That's just one number.
Well, we know some things, which
are actually very interesting.
So Coedes was an amazing guy.
He wasn't a
mathematician at all,
but he was fascinated
by mathematics.
I don't remember the
exact way it works.
But numbers in the east
were often given names.
So you'd say, the veda,
and there are four vedas.
So the number four is veda.
You say veda, it means four.
Eyes means two, obviously.
And census, I think, is
five, or something like that.
And flavors is six.
I may be confusing them.
But every number of the
first few numbers has a word.
And it's like a code.
And you'd say, I'll
meet you at-- I
don't know-- a particular
street, veda eyes census,
and you know
exactly where it is.
And he traces that, how they
do arithmetic with that.
That would be a good question,
whether eyes plus eyes
would be whatever four is.
Well, veda.
Veda is eyes plus
eyes, or eyes square.
So I don't know if they
did arithmetic that way.
Coedes started and
made a lot of progress.
But it stopped.
We know nothing.
There are thousands
of steles in Cambodia.
You go to museums, and they
have them in their store rooms.
And he was a genius.
He was just able to translate.
He did 2,000 of them.
And that's it.
Nobody knows.
Nobody has consistently
studied these further.
Why?
I have no idea.
Maybe they just
have no resources.
I guess I do know why.
You don't want to
justify colonialism.
But France says resources, and
Coedes wasn't just by himself.
The was the Ecole
Francais d'Extreme Orient,
which is the French School
of the Far East, I guess,
the extreme Orient.
And they had a lot of money,
and they could do things.
That's why they
were able to do it.
Now, the Cambodians
go to Palermo
to get somebody to teach them
how to restore artifacts.
So I think that's
where the problem lies.
Somebody needs
to-- there are tons
of these things that
need to be translated.
This is one of only
2,000, 3,000 inscriptions
that have been translated.
And there are
probably-- well, I don't
know how many there
are in Cambodia.
In India, there are millions.
And they still need
to be translated.
The problem with the
dating, again, a few of you
alluded to is how do we
know that it's the date?
That's a huge problem in India.
So in India, the dates
are very, very murky.
And the reason is that many
of the inscriptions in India
are on copper plates.
And the date is always on the
side, or often on the side.
And you don't know if it was
added five centuries later
or whatever.
So the dates are very fishy.
And that allows somebody
like Raju to claim,
we invented everything.
On the other hand, they probably
did have a lot of science,
astronomy in particular,
and a lot of mathematics
that they did develop.
But it's all hidden.
Nobody has translated
these things.
And nobody knows the
dates with precision.
Here, we are lucky.
The good thing is
that it's in stone.
It looks like it
hasn't been-- doesn't
look to me like somebody
could have come in 1932
and chiseled that 605.
There are forgeries.
I studied one of them,
a very interesting one.
Maybe you know that story about
the Drake Plate in California.
Many years-- it was discovered
by a Professor at Berkeley.
And it was in the trunk of
his car for several years.
And this is Francis
Drake put this plate here
on the California coast,
commemorating his arrival there
by Point Reyes Peninsula.
And they found it was fake.
The copper was made
using modern techniques.
And the script wasn't
Elizabethan at all.
It was forgery.
So there are forgeries.
There are lots of people
who have an incentive
to forge things.
And so this, you never know.
I don't think this is fake.
And the cool thing is
that we have that date.
And it happens to have a zero.
And the same, in India,
the Gwalior zero is 270.
And it looks just
like our numerals,
even though it's ninth century.
The two looks like that.
It's a very overdone two.
And the zero is a circle.
I'm sorry, the seven
actually goes back very far.
The seven is one of
the first numerals that
remained the same from its
inception, whatever that means.
I've looked at a lot of
these scripts in India.
There's Brahmi
numerals, and Ashoka
was a Buddhist king in
India, first few centuries.
And he had pillars
all over India-- maybe
you know-- they're
very famous pillars.
And there are numerals
on them, and the numerals
are called Ashoka numerals.
Both Ashoka
numerals, and there's
a Naneghat cave in the Western
Ghats, southeast of Mumbai.
And you can go up there.
It's a long hike to the top.
There are numerals there called
the Naneghat inscription.
So there are these
three scripts that
go back the first few centuries,
two, three centuries AD.
They're all around
the same time.
I think Ashoka is about
the third century,
or maybe it's 300 or so.
So all three of them have a
seven that's just like ours,
without the-- just a
seven the way we write it,
not the way European
write it, crossing it.
So the seven is one of the first
numerals that just traveled
through time to us
exactly as it is.
So you have the
seven, and then you
have a zero in India,
the Gwalior zero.
Now, there's another
way-- there are
many ways of dating things
that can authenticate them
quite well.
I'll get to you
in a second-- that
can authenticate
them quite well.
This is one example.
It's not unique,
but it's very clear.
You have a date.
It has a zero in it.
And you know when
that dynasty started.
That dynasty started in
78, so we know the date.
When you go earlier
in history, there's
something very interesting
that can be done,
and that is early civilizations
like the Babylonians were
very careful in recording
total solar eclipses.
They were very obsessed with
Venus and not the phases,
they couldn't see them,
but the motions of Venus
when it rises with
the sun and so on.
And they also were interested
in total solar eclipses.
So they tell you
something happened.
The king died, whatever
king died on the day of,
or five days after the
total solar eclipse.
You can find it exactly because
you use modern astronomy.
You go back in time
roughly, and you
know where the eclipse
path past on a certain time
on a certain day
in a certain year.
And that has been
used, actually,
to establish a lot of Assyrian,
Babylonian chronology.
So that's another very
nice modern method.
And of course,
radiocarbon is unbeatable.
I've worked a little,
devised a statistical routine
for making radiocarbon more
precise using the bootstrap.
And the radiocarbon
is now, I don't know,
50 years or within
a few centuries.
So it's very accurate.
AUDIENCE: Would you speak to the
difference between the numeral
zero and the number zero?
In particular, I'm
thinking imagining
a record of an
inventory that might
say, number of bushels
of wheat, zero.
Number of jars of
wine, zero, which
is distinct from the use of
the numeral as a placeholder.
But the numeral to
represent the number zero.
AMIR ACZEL: Right.
So the way I understand it, that
is a sophisticated idea, too.
In the west, at least, it was
difficult for people to say,
we have zero
bottles of wine left
for the holiday, or
something like that.
And my understanding is that the
double-- what do you call it?
The bookkeeping method,
double entry bookkeeping
evolved because of that
inability to say there's zero.
So you have numbers
of one kind here
and numbers of the
other kind there.
What you owe, what you
are owed, and so on.
Yeah, it takes a little
sophistication to say,
we have zero of something.
Negative numbers are even worse.
What do negative numbers mean?
So when you study mathematics
and you look at the numbers,
how they evolved, the idea of
numbers, how we perceive them,
the positive, the natural
numbers and natural to us.
One, two, three, four, five,
even if they go on to infinity.
In order to define the negative
numbers, you need a zero.
Because the zero is
the point of symmetry
where the natural numbers
go to the right, and then
the negative ones
go to the left.
And you can have a
group under addition
where you have the inverse
is the minute you have
the negative numbers,
and you have a zero.
So the zero is the
additive identity.
The multiplicative
identity would be one.
So then you can have a field.
So yes, it's a
sophisticated idea.
It was slow in the west.
I don't know, in
the east, it seems
to have been more
natural, maybe.
I feel, and I have no
strong proof of that,
and infinity also is an
idea that was maybe easier
to evolve in the east, just
having read a lot of stuff
about the east.
In Hinduism, there's an
infinite sea, and the sea turtle
on which Vishnu lies when
Brahma springs out of his navel.
It's called Ananta,
which means infinity.
So there are ideas of infinity.
They didn't understand them.
But they could talk about them
maybe more than in the west.
Because Augustine writes
about the infinitude of God
in certain ways.
So infinity as well-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: In the system
where the designation is just
a blank space, like 60 is 6,
or 601 is 6, blank space, 1,
how would you judge when
there's more than one space?
And if there's more than
one, is it two or three?
In order to really do
that with any accuracy,
you need something in there,
a little jot of some kind.
AUDIENCE: Or it could
be clear columns.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AMIR ACZEL: Good
point, good point.
That's why the zero
is so important.
You don't know how
many blanks are there.
And the blanks
also, remember, they
didn't have anything
standardized
like you'd print on a page,
and a blank is an exact width.
This was written by
hand, or chiseled.
And how do you know if
there's a blank there,
or just the guy couldn't
judge distances very well?
Especially if the
distances vary,
there's no way to tell where
there's a blank unless it's
really a significant width.
So that's a good point.
But you could-- going back
to your previous question,
you could assume-- and
what somebody else asked,
too, and commented on-- a
blank could be quite rationally
a void.
And maybe it's
not that Buddhist.
Maybe it's an idea
that came other ways.
Going back to infinity,
infinity really
was understood with the work of
Cantor in the 1800s in Germany.
So infinity really becomes
a mathematical concept
in the late 1800s.
But maybe what I'm
trying to say is
that eastern people
talked more about infinity
than people in the west.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just on the subject
of multiple zeroes in a row,
I'm trying to remember
the tables of chords
in Ptolemy's Almagest, which
is second century AD, right?
Which has trigonometric
functions of every half degree
value between 0 and
whatever they went up to,
30 degrees or
something like that,
for trigonometric calculations.
There's calculations
in the Almagest
that certainly go out to like
five places in sexidecimal
or something like that.
So certainly, there
must been calculations
that they were doing
at that time, all
the trigonometric calculations
that they were doing
that involved multiple
zeroes in a row.
It seems very unlikely
that they would never
have hit two adjacent base
60 slots that were empty.
But of course, all
their calculations
were done in very strict
tables, these tables
of values of the
chord function had
the firsts, and the seconds,
and thirds, and the fourths,
and the fifths, which are
fractional powers of 60,
all lined up with each other.
So I don't know how Ptolemy
actually wrote it, though.
AMIR ACZEL: You're right.
If you're careful
with writing a table
and there are five zeroes
that have to be there,
so there are five blank columns,
or whatever, however they
did it.
That makes sense.
Yes.
So they must have
had a technology.
So maybe ours is
more advanced just
in the sense it's standardized.
You have a zero,
so you don't have
to worry about making
a table and columns.
So the ideas must have
been there early on.
But maybe they don't agree
with our sense of neatness
and keeping things
much more universal.
So you can write a number
here and read it in Japan,
and it makes sense that it's
1,005 and not something else.
So good point, good point.
They did have very
extensive tables, right?
Good.
Any other questions?
Well, thank you very much
for having me come here.
[APPLAUSE]